[Music]
talking about stress this is not
stressful at all um
but it's really nice to be back here
this used to be my first conference talk
ever in 2016 so i'm really really happy
to be to be back here at csgo of
budapest thank you all for coming
um
yeah
and um they just already asked the
question who has any clue what jose is
about
and i think i see one or two hands it's
a bit difficult but that's very good
because it means that you'll learn at
least one thing today i'm not going to
spoil what it is yet because we're going
to work our way up to jose
but it is somewhat related to
cryptography and don't be scared the
most difficult part of this talk is for
me at least pronouncing cryptography
you'll hear me struggle with it the
whole time um but
let's get started we only have half an
hour so let me quickly introduce myself
my name is sam bellum i'm a developer
advocate engineer at all xero we have a
booth outside if you want to learn more
if you have any questions afterwards i'm
a google developer expert and if you
want to find me on the internet just
look for some meigo
um i'm a d i'm a developer my javascript
developer should only make sense to
myself that i'm nbm installable so if
you're on mpx add some mega slash about
me download half of the internet wait a
few few seconds
you'll find all of my social links and
links to my current and past
presentations
if you'd like to follow along now or
after this talk or anytime in the future
these slides are available and will
always be available at jose.commega.tech
open them on your phone just pay
attention to me whatever you prefer
um but i have to start with a few
disclaimers because this is a
cryptography talk um and the first one
is i might i will simplify certain
things in order to try to explain them
in an easier way cryptography gets
complicated really fast but we're only
going to stay on the surface level of
this
and second don't prevent the wheel when
you're dealing with something quick
cryptography um use one of the existing
libraries they're made by experts by
professionals who knows what they're
doing please use what's out there
already and don't try to write your own
unless you really know what you're doing
okay so in this talk we're going to have
a quick summary of hashing and key
testing signing digital signatures
encryption and lastly we're going to
explain what this whole thing is all
about um but let's dive straight into it
so we start with hashing um and a
hashing algorithm is a mathematical
algorithm that maps data of an arbitrary
size to a bit string of a fixed size a
lot of fancy words for just saying no
matter how much input you put into this
algorithm the output will always be the
same size and that size is defined by
the algorithm
the initial data is often called the
message and the outcome is called a hash
or a message digest so if i reference to
a hash or a message digest that's what
comes out of a hashing algorithm
and it's a one way function which means
you can put something in it you'll get
your hash but you will never be able or
you should never be able to reverse that
hash back to the original message it's a
one-way function if you go through it
you can reverse whatever happened in
that algorithm um so if we look at a
little example we have three different
different uh inputs dark doggo the quick
brown fox jumps over the lazy dog all
three have a different length they're
longer words they're a sentence
but the output of this algorithm in this
case sha-256 will have a 256-bit outcome
and that's one of the characteristics of
a hash the output will always be of a
fixed bit length no matter how big the
input it's a one-way function so you see
that the errors go one way you should
never be able to reverse them
um and some common algorithms are md5
shell one two three and tlm and so forth
and so forth if you've been doing stuff
on the internet you might have used md5
in the past we don't use it that often
anymore because there's some security
implications but um it's still around
these days we use usually use one of the
uh shots um to do hashing on the
internet so we've seen hashing a quick
overview of what hashing is one way
function always fixed length output
can't reverse it uh key attaching is
just a extra bit on top of regular
hashing so everything we just learned
about hashing is still true for keith
hashing but we're just going to add a
little bit extra um so kit hashes lets
you validate the integrity and
authenticity of the content of the hash
so how can you do this how can we
validate the integrity the fact that
nobody tried to tamper with whatever
content has been hashed um well in
combination which is the hashing
algorithm it is also going to use a
secret key you can also call this a
password or something similar
but it's a secret key on top of a
hashing algorithm
so same example dog dog or quickbang fox
but instead of running them through a
regular shot 256 algorithm relating to
we're running them to a through a key
dashing algorithm in this case h-max
shot 256 so it still uses a shot 256 but
adds hmac on top of that and together
with the inputs we also have a secret
and if we change that secret the output
will also change so the output is
dependent on not only the input but also
the added
secret
um this means that we can validate the
input we don't have to know the exact
input of the hash but if we know the
secret and the
the exact the input we can see we can
validate that the hashes are what we
expect them to be because in hash for an
input is always going to be the same for
the same input so if you know the key we
know the input we can say that for
certainty uh nothing has changed to the
input so it lets us validate integrity
of data in certain instances
and some of the key testing algorithms
are hmac shot 256 384 512 these are just
the bit lengths of the outputs but hmac
sha is the most commonly used keyed
hashing algorithm i'm going really fast
because i have a lot of things to say
but if you have questions please come up
to me afterwards at the odd0 booth
and some example use cases when you
store passwords you don't store them in
plain text please don't store them in
plain text you usually do a lot of
things with them you might salt them but
you probably also use a hashing
algorithm or a key hashing algorithm to
store them in your databases
but you can also do things like
identifying files cache busting database
indexes and even things in blockchain
use hashes
cool that was a real short overview of
hashes and key dashes let's move on to
the next step digital signatures or
signing um and digital signatures offer
all properties that kit hashes do so
anything that was true for kitash is
still true for a digital signature but
they also offer this one very difficult
to pronounce thing called cryptographic
non-repudiation and if you look this up
on it on wikipedia it tells you
non-repudiation refers to a situation
where a statements author cannot
successfully dispute its authorship or
the validity of an associated contract
clear right
what it means is basically this
cryptographic no repudiation can prove
whoever created the signature because we
added that little piece on top of it the
cryptographic repudiation we should be
able to prove who created the signature
with the keith hash anybody that has
access to the secret to the secret can
create a keith hash with a cryptic
cryptographic signature only a certain
person or party should be able to create
them in their own name and the way we do
this is um
using public key cryptography or
asymmetric cryptography so the same
thing they use two different things one
to create something i want to validate
something and to create signatures to
create a signature designer the person
that wants to create the signature is
going to create a signature using their
private key and a private key is
something that you link to yourself that
you keep secret to yourself that you
don't share with anybody ever you're
going to use a private key to generate
your signature and then you can share
that signature with whoever needs to
have your digital signature um and they
can ask for your public key and based on
the public key they can validate that
the signature is still valid or not that
the content that you try to sign has not
been tampered with and so forth but
you're only sharing your public key you
never share your private key um and we
use a private key to create a signature
and we use a public key to validate a
signature and this basically allows us
to do this cryptographic non-repudiation
thing that i just talked about we own
the public key we can confirm that this
digital signature has been made by our
public key so they can prove that i made
that signature
assigning algorithm is usually
collection of three different algorithms
it's something that creates a public and
private key pair which are
mathematically linked something that's
used that uses the private key to create
a signature and something that uses the
public key to verify a signature um
so if you look at the same examples
before a bit simplified we still have an
input it's still a one-way function but
instead of adding our
shared secret we are now using our
private key to create the signature
which will give us an output usually
this is based on a hash as well so it's
usually also with a fixed uh length of
output
um and if we want to validate the
signature we'll need the original input
we'll need the signature and we need a
public key that has been linked to the
private key that created the signature
and if we have all those three pieces of
data which should be public data we can
validate that nothing in the original
input has been tampered with that it is
what we expect it to be that develop
that the digital signature is valid or
not um so use public key to validate the
private key to generate a signature
um and some signing algorithms the most
commonly used ones there's a whole bunch
of them there's a few families rsa is
the most common one that you've elliptic
curve and a we also have edwards curve
i'm not going to go into details if
you'd like to talk details again come
find me in the booth but we don't have
time for this um and some common use
cases json web tokens if you use json
tokens before they're usually signed
sometimes they use a key test for the
signature but most of the time it's
recommended to use a digital signing
algorithm and if you want to sign a
document online usually you run that
document to a signing algorithm and you
create a digital digital signature as
well so there's a few a few example use
cases
so we can move on to the next and the
last part of our introduction to
cryptography encryption
um and when encrypting data we cannot
only ensure that the integrity and
authenticity is what we want it to be
what we expect it to be like with
signatures and what like with keith
hashing but the data will also stay
secret forever for outsider anybody that
should not be able to read the data will
not should not be able to read the data
with signatures the data would be public
with encrypted data that encrypted data
is encrypted for anybody who does not
know how to decrypt that data
and you either need a private key a
secret qr password depending on which
kind of algorithm you're using but you
can use any of these to encrypt and
decrypt data
the output of encryption algorithm is
often called a cipher when i say cipher
i mean what comes out of an encryption
algorithm or what goes into a decryption
algorithm
so there's two kinds of encryption you
have symmetric af asymmetric symmetric
is the most simple one
and we use these often for very big
pieces of data if we have to store if
you have to encrypt a lot of data at
once uh things like a whole file system
your whole hard drive all your network
network traffic on your wi-fi databases
we usually use a asymmetric algorithm
just because they're a bit easier to
compute a bit faster to compute they're
easier or better to deal with large
pieces of data
and the same example if you'd like to
encrypt the quick brown fox we run it
through the encryption algorithm
together with a shared secret or a
password and we get our cipher or
encrypted message we can then decrypt so
this is not a one-way function this is a
two-way function you can decrypt that
that cipher back if you also know the
shared secret and it's good to know that
with a symmetrical algorithm you use a
shared secret to both encrypt and
decrypted data it's a bit more simple
that's why we use it for
simple in terms of cryptography that's
why we use it with large pieces of data
but use the same shared secret or
password to do both the encrypting and
decrypting
which is different from asymmetrical
encryption
where you first are going to send
as the sender somebody that wants to
encrypt the the data for the public key
and a publicly you can share so anybody
can share their public key with you and
you're then going to use a public key to
encrypt the message this is a different
mindset from digital signatures where
you use the private key to create the
signature and the public key to validate
with encryption is the other way around
at least mentally you ask somebody's
public key to to encrypt the message and
then they can use their private key
which they keep
which they keep to themselves to decrypt
this this means that nobody accepts
whoever owns that private key can
decrypt a message which means that the
contents of that message would stay
secret for the whole world except
whoever owns that private key which is
great that's why encryption is invented
so same example but instead of using one
shared secret we use a public key to
encrypt it and we use a private key to
decrypt the message
asymmetric encryption some use cases tls
vpn ssh there's a lot of use cases but
anytime when you're not using with a big
piece of data or you want more security
you often use an asymmetrical algorithm
and some of these are the ones listed on
the slides rsa oap twice for some reason
i don't know why i did that but yup
so let's look at a little detailed
example of rsa and encryption before we
move on to the actual subject jose
the first thing we need to do when
encrypting something with an
asymmetrical algorithm like rsa is
is generate a public and private key
pair
and when you do this cryptography is
often based on very large prime numbers
and when i speak about very large prime
numbers do i mean a million do i mean a
billion
i mean something like this where this
would be a million this would be a
billion and have no idea how to
pronounce or name the actual number on
screen but you're dealing with with
numbers with numbers that have 150 300
digits a lot of a lot of digits very
very big prime numbers that are really
hard to compute and because they're
really hard to compute that's what makes
it so secure to do cryptography with
them
so if you want to generate a public and
private key for rsa we're first going to
going to generate two very large prime
numbers 61 and 53 are not large but for
the sake of this demo i'm choosing small
ones in reality they're going to be very
large numbers
then you're going to generate a lambda
which is just a lambda function that you
throw in the first and second prime
number so you have these three values
are you going to keep these values
secret somewhere in memory but you're
going to use those three values to
generate the public key and the private
key that way they are somehow
mathematically linked and the public key
is going to going to contain the modulus
n which is the first pound number times
the seconds and it's also going to
contain the public exponent which is a
coprime of that lambda value we
calculated earlier and then the private
key is also going to contain that
modulus but instead of the public
exponent is containing the private
exponent which is whatever you see in
the mathematic mathematical function at
the bottom of the screen but because
they use those three values we calculate
it in the yellow box at the top they are
mathematically linked and once we
generated those two keys we can forget
about the prime numbers and the nominal
value we don't need them anymore we only
need the data the numbers inside of our
public and private key
so using the public key to encrypt data
is as simple as having some input one
two three four it's a nice number we run
it to that algorithm in the middle of
the yellow box and plug in the n the
modulus and the public exponent
values and if we do so we get another
number two one eight three let's
remember this one because we're going to
decrypt this later
but usually we don't deal with numbers
we deal with any other file types you
might have to do a better file file type
conversion but under the hoot whenever
you encrypt something you're always
going to be doing a mathematical
algorithm some mathematical calculations
so any type you put into an encryption
algorithm it's going to convert it to
numbers first and then do the encryption
and then maybe convert it back to
something that you expect it to be
so we got a cipher two one eight
something now we need to decrypt it
again to be able to get to the original
data which was one two three four
um so we do that we take this one two
one eight three plug it into the
algorithm in the yellow box which is the
rsa decryption algorithm together with
the exponent with the modulus and the
private exponent find on a private key
and if all works out and i've done my
math right we should end up with the
original message which in this case was
one two three four so
it's just a bunch of mathematics under
the hood and because you are basing both
keys the public key in the private key
on a bunch of common numbers so super
numbers and that lambda they're
mathematically linked some very um
clever mathematics mathematicians
figured out that they could do it that
way um so it works again usually you
don't work with numbers but with
something else so there's a bunch of
data conversion going on before and
after your encryption and decryption but
under the hoot it's just a mathematical
function
cool so we have 40 minutes left to go
into jose which is perfect if you'd like
to know more about rsa i created this
little demo website called rsa.comtech
it's a work in progress doesn't work in
safari but if you go to it
you'll see that you can enter a message
on the top and enter anything and it
will decrypt this message using rsa i
would also give you a bit of an
explanation at the bottom showing you
all the numbers it uses and as you can
see these are quite big numbers that it
uses to do the actual encryption and
decryption
and it gives you a nice explanation of
how these numbers are used to encrypt
and decrypt the data so if you're
interested in this
rsa.somebody.tech
check it out later or tomorrow or next
year it doesn't really matter
it's always going to be there hopefully
it will be finished monday soon
um so let's move on to jose and i've
asked this before who knows jose i think
i saw one or two hands i'm not sure
because some lies are my face but i
think i saw one or two hands um
and jose stands for json object signing
and encryption and these are words we
know by now we all know jason
yes right yeah
we all know what an object is this is a
javascript conference so i think most of
us know what an object is and we've seen
what signing and encryption is in the in
the previous slides of this talk so all
of these sends these words make somehow
sense to us in some kind of way so jose
is just an acronym for jose for json
object signing and encryption which is a
group of specifications that specifies a
lot of things and the most common one is
json web tokens who's used adjacent web
token before
that's a lot of hands see all of you
have used who have to use jose before
without even realizing that you were
using jose or a specification that is
part of the jose specification but json
web tokens are not the only
specification in the jose specification
i've been saying specification a lot of
a lot of times but um there's a bunch of
them in there but first why json
well the json format is often used for
serializing and transmitting structured
data over a network connection which
means we use json on the internet all
the time
it has excellent support in most
programming languages especially in
javascript since it came from javascript
so we all know how to deal with json in
javascript in most programming languages
so it's an easy very commonly used
language let's call it um so it
specifies there's a bunch of different
specifications
jsonwebsomethingsj7 tokens is one that i
mentioned before but there's a bunch of
others in there and the first one is a
json web key and json webkey is
basically just json represent
representation of a public or private
key um that you can use on the web and
because a private key is something you
keep to yourself most of the time this
is going to be a public key that you can
share with others in the form of json so
if you look at an example you see that
we have a keys array which can contain
more keys but in this case it just
contains one it tells us it's for an
rs256 algorithm it's an rsa type of
algorithm tells us a bit more but it
also tells us the n and the e value and
if you've paid attention to how we
generated the keys in the rsa example we
created a modulus and a public exponent
the modulus is the n version the n the n
thingy and the public exponent is the
eve thingy so these are the two numbers
that we generated in an example you will
also find them in this rsa key if you
use different algorithms they will
contain different kinds of data
depending on the algorithm but it's
basically just a json representation of
a public or private key you can use to
encrypt decrypt verify sign things on
the web cool next up isn't json web
signature um and if you used if you use
json updates before this might look
familiar it's basically a long string
with two dots in the middle separating
three different parts
and if you know how to read these it's a
base64 encoded json object.base64
encoded json object dot a signature um
and if you look into the first one the
hoisa header it will tell us what this
signature which algorithm has been used
to create the signature hs256 in this
case
the payload is the second part can be
anything valid json so anything that's
valid json booleans numbers strings
objects arrays all valid json you can
put in there as a basic c4 encoded
string and lastly the signature is
basically taking that header taking that
payload running it through whatever
signature uh signature algorithm you
specified in the header this is the key
hashing algorithm but most of the time
you use a signature assigning algorithm
and you get it you get a signature
um so that was really short
you have a header you have a payload the
actual science data and then you
generate a signature on that on on those
those pieces of data um and you get it
back as a string so you can send it
easily over the network because it's
quite compact as a string
the next part is a jwe json web
encryption and this is a little bit more
complex
because it's not just three parts it
usually or it always consists out of
five parts the first part is familiar
it's again the header the thing that is
going to tell us a bit more information
about the actual encrypted cipher that
we are trying to sell sent in this
instance um next up is djw e encrypted
key and this is an encrypted key that we
need to decrypt first but once we've
decrypted this key we can use this key
to decrypt the actual cipher so jwe is
encrypted using two different kinds of
encryption symmetric and asymmetric
we'll see in a second how this actually
works but the second part is that
encrypted key that we need to decrypt
first then you have the initialization
vector and the authentication tag at the
end which we can use to decrypt as well
and the fourth part decipher text is the
actual encrypted message that we want to
send along sha w e it's the actual
encrypted method that we want to decrypt
um so i mentioned this already jlbe is
used to kind of encryption the content
encryption key is usually encrypted with
an asymmetrically asymmetrical key
asymmetrical because the key is
relatively short we we know what the
size of it so we're going to use a more
secure but a bit more complex algorithm
just to encrypt that uh that that
encryption key
and the uh
okay so it's the second part the cipher
is encrypted using a symmetrical
algorithm because a cipher can be any
piece of data can be a huge piece of
data and we've seen that we usually use
symmetrical algorithms for that um so
that's encrypted using a symmetrical
error
algorithm and that uses the content
encryption key in the jle itself to
decrypt so let's see how we do this the
first thing we look inside of the hose
header and it tells us a few things
tells us which algorithm to use to
decrypt the encounter encryption key
decrypt the cipher and also tells us the
id of the private key we need to use to
decrypt that content encryption key so
the first thing we need to do is decrypt
that content encryption key the second
part of our of our large string
so we see that we need to use rsaoap for
this content encryption key we take the
that library that knows how to deal with
that that's algorithm um pass along the
content encryption key the encrypted
content encryption key together with the
private key of which we'll find the id
in the header as well and if all things
work out well we get a decrypted content
encryption key which means a content
encryption key that we can actually use
to decrypt our jwe or cipher in this jwe
so to grip the actual cipher we're going
to look in our header again we see that
we have to use the a2256 gcm algorithm
here which is a symmetrical algorithm
and it accepts a few things in this case
the cipher the actual encrypted message
in this jwe
the decrypted content encryption key so
the decrypted key that we decrypted in
the previous step together with the
initialization vector which is a third
part and the authentication tag which is
the fifth part sometimes the
initialization vector is empty but
that's just uh an fyi but if you put
them all in to an algorithm or a library
that knows how to deal with this
algorithm in the end you're going to get
your decrypt message so it's a bit more
complex you have to deal with two kinds
of encryption two at least two different
uh kinds of two different algorithms you
first have to decrypt your content
encryption key before you can use that
actual key to decrypt the cipher but if
you've done everything right you have a
decrypted message that was sent to you
as a big string
early on
um and it's good to know that both json
web signatures and json web encryption
can be serialized as compact a string so
for a signature that's in three parts
and for three parts and for the jwe
that's five parts but it's called json
object signing an encryption so there
should also be a json variant of this
otherwise the name wouldn't make much
sense
so you can also serialize these as a
bunch of json now usually when we deal
with json wrap tokens jws is an ease we
sterilize them as compact as a string
just because it's more compact to send
over the network but if you want to deal
with the data and we want to deal with
the data in a more readable way in a
more structured way you can always
format them as json and this would be an
example of a jws where you see the same
things you see the payload you see the
header you see the signature so you have
all these pieces of data that are in the
compact string but just represent it as
a json object and this would be a jwe
and again you see your tag your
initialization the authentication tag
your ciphertext your initialization
vector all the things that are in that
big string can also be represented as a
piece of json if it's easier for you to
work like this
so let's move on to the next one json
web tokens well adjacent up token is
usually just or is always just a jws or
jwe
serialized as a compact string so the
string version
and 99.99 of the time it's going to be
ajws in the compact version but it
doesn't have to be um if you want to
keep the data inside of your payload
secure for the outside world you can
also use a jwe serialized as compact the
one with the five parts as a json web
token most of the time this is overkill
but if you really are concerned with the
security or privacy or whatever in your
payload you can use a jw e for it as
well
but most of the time we use jws because
it's way more simple easier to use
so
um again we have a json web token header
and next to the algorithm that has been
used to create the signature or the
algorithms that have been used to
encrypt and the the decipher it also
tells us i am a json web token and
sometimes it tells you even a bit more
about which kind of json web token it is
so if you look at a few examples the
first one an access token an access
token is used to get access to an api so
the payload of a json wrap token is
going that is being used as an access
token is going to contain some
information that's useful to an api so
who issued this your authorization
server the subject for which user is
this access token and the audience for
which api is this access token and this
can be multiple when it's issued at when
it expires at some scopes but all
information that is useful for an ad for
an api to get access to an api
an id token is another example of json
web tokens which is specified by the
open id connect specification and id
token contains some information about
the identity of somebody that
authenticated
so instead of having data that's useful
for an api this is going to contain data
that is related to the identity of
somebody that that authenticated things
like a nickname or a name or a picture
maybe
a subject is a user id but again all
data that is related to the identity of
somebody that authenticated and the last
example is a depop proof depop stands
for demonstratable proof of possession
which basically means that you can prove
that you own a certain access token
and it's going to contain some
information related to that it's going
to contain um some json web token id um
for which um url this is supposed to be
used for which method um but depending
on the use case of a json web token the
payload is always going to contain data
that is relevant for its use case so
there's no standard payload there's a
bunch of different ways and anything
that's well adjacent and of concern or
useful for you you can put inside of
that payload
so let's summarize
hashing compresses and makes it
virtually impossible uh to get to the
real data it's a one-way function the
output is always going to be a fixed bit
length depending on the algorithm under
the algorithm
kit hashes do everything that a hash
does but it also protects the integrity
of the data because you also need to
know the secret key in order to to
calculate the right keyed hash
digital signatures allow third parties
to verify the validity and origin of
data just because you you use
a private key to generate a signature
and anybody that has access to your
public key which is public data can use
a public key to validate that signature
encryption allows only authorized people
to read the data so you you usually um
either use a password or a secret string
and then encrypt and decrypt that or if
you use an asymmetrical algorithm you
use your public key somebody's public
key to encrypt a message and then they
can use their own private key to read
the data which means that nobody else
should be able to read or decrypt that
piece of
data
and jose is a set of standards based on
the json that helps us with signatures
and encryption on the web you have two
different kinds you have the compact
version which is the
jws as a string with three parts or as
in jw but as five parts but you also
have a json version which is easier to
read and it's easy to work with as a
developer depending on your use case you
can choose both unless you use json web
tokens then they're always going to be
the compact string version because you
send them over the network a lot of
times
these slides are available and will
always be available in some kind of way
at jose.sumbego.tech
jwtwo if you want to know more about
json up tokens
rsa.somebig.tech if you want to see that
rsa little website thingy that i'm
building and that i demoed a few slides
back
if you want to learn more about sha-256
um it's very very complex and somebody
built a website that explains chat 256
there's a lot of things going on but
it's really worth it to take a look at
it if you want to understand better how
it works it's way more complex than the
rsa example that i gave today
but it's a really cool website
that being said thank you very much